Willkommen im Course Einführung in Adobe Illustrator.
Ich zeige euch in diesem Course,
wie man mit Adobe Illustrator erste technische
Modezeichnungen erstellen kann.
Adobe Illustrator ist ein relativ komplexes Programm,
das auch in vielen Berufsfeldern genutzt wird.
In der Modebranche benutzen wir es hauptsächlich zur
Erstellung von technischen Modezeichnungen.
Ich habe den Course deshalb so strukturiert,
dass du nach und nach in essenzielle Funktionen des
Programms eingeführt wirst, und zwar in diese,
die du brauchst, um technische Modezeichnungen zu erstellen.
Du lernst also Schritt für Schritt einige Tools kennen und
kannst dein Wissen Kurs für Kurs erweitern.
Wir legen jetzt los mit Adobe Illustrator.
Zunächst öffnest du das Programm.
Du klickst also auf Adobe Illustrator und du wirst sehen,
oben links kannst du auf neue Datei gehen.
Oder wenn es mal etwas schneller gehen soll,
kannst du auch auf schnell eine neue Datei erstellen gehen.
Das machen wir jetzt. Klick also hier auf A4 und
schon öffnet sich eine
Datei Du siehst jetzt eine weiße Seite.
Das ist deine Zeichenfläche.
Das ist quasi wie ein weißes Platt Papier, nur digital.
Mit den meisten Programmen findest du oben eine Menüleiste.
Die wollen wir uns jetzt einmal anschauen.
Unter dem Menü Datei kannst du eine neue Datei anlegen oder
eine Datei oder eine bestehende Datei
Öffnen.
Das Menü bearbeiten bietet Optionen wie
einfügen, rückgängig
Machen.
Danach folgen die Menüs Objekt,
Schrift,
Auswahl, Effekt und Ansicht.
Das sind Menüs auf die ich später eingehen werde.
Dann gibt es das Menü Fenster.
Das finde ich ein relativ wichtiges Menü,
denn hier kannst du Bedienfelder oder
Werkzeuge öffnen bzw.
ein und ausblenden.
Also, falls dir mal etwas fehlt,
kannst du hier einfach nachschauen.
Zuletzt haben wir das Menü Hilfe.
Hier findest du einige Tutorials und
Antworten auf eventuelle
Fragen.
Wenn du dir jetzt deinen Bildschirm anschaust,
fällt dir vielleicht links eine Werkzeugleiste
Auf.
Die kannst du ganz nach deinem Geschmack anpassen.
Ich mag sie gern etwas kompakter,
also klicke ich hier auf diesen Doppelfeil und schon ist sie
in einem anderen Format.